okay we're
live
hi and take a quick look at the puffer
Discord see if there's anything to fix
major here and uh if not continue on
some of the infrastructure work that I'm
doing
friend friend
[Music]
uh that already got it see look how
helpful the community is gets it before
I do
[Music]
uh yeah so he's just he needs to figure
this thing out how
do test stuff
locally oo look at
this not bad doesn't have the ghost
which is the main
main thing
very nice Pac-Man
end uh the ghost or the hard part is the
thing though
oh this is from AI That's
funny
uh no I don't think this is true
yeah tortur is decent um does sometimes
break some stuff
okay so uh we're all caught up on this
we can start on some Dev here going to
just do a
quick hour and a half session is uh
right now before I head to brunch it is
Sunday I normally don't do stuff on on
Sunday but I've been lazing all week and
there's work to
do so I figured I'd Dev and I figured I
may as well stream
okay this still
works now test
well uh okay good so now I just have to
make the
native puffer environments work with
this which shouldn't be very hard
because of the way that I've
restructured
everything so what I was doing
before is I just made the puffer uh
ocean environments they just match the
vector
API so you just make it and that's it um
but if you want to do multiple of those
on one
subprocess there's one other API thing
that has to match
multiprocessing so native with 1 M
should still work
right
work yes so this still works and still
trains but now the thing that we're
going to
do that will be a little
this is going to be a little awkward um
so it's going to be
back
multiprocessing still works and is
somehow
faster oh no we know that that's faster
that's
fine um and then we have to
do num
so what this is
saying yeah okay so we now we have to
check on this but what this is saying is
that we want to we want to have U
multiple puffer M's per process because
there are only two workers two
processes and they're going to be four
environments uh so this is an unrelated
issue I believe believe so let's just
do can I do this m
do M uh two can I do
this no I didn't actually configure
that I might as well add that
uh so what we'll do for
now just for hey welcome that you
spener yeah there twitch twitch has
faster chat and doesn't drop your
messages so good Fair choice
all right let's see if this
works we're just doing some infr patches
um this is going to be very convenient
for new people for puffer because what
this is essentially going to let you do
is let's say you want to use the new
puffer M API but you want to just Dev in
Python uh this will let you just Dev
really simple in Python still get some
of the speed UPS uh but then it's like a
cleaner path right like to optimize cuz
if you just write gymnasium M you're
screwed like there's no way to make it
fast regardless of what you do but uh if
you write it in our API then you have a
very clean onboarding ramp to go like
from python to scon to C it's built for
Edition uh it's the same thing Spencer
it's just annoying because you have to
write the loop in Python like the
loopover environments in Python and the
environment in Python at the moment so
that's going to go away but it's the
same thing you just write the logic in
Python instead of in
C there's no point though it's literally
once you get comfortable it's just as
easy to do it in see and all your speed
problems go away the only thing that's a
little annoying at the moment is like
The scyon Binding
intermediary I really like scyon though
because it gives you the option to Dev
stuff that's fast but looks like python
I don't know maybe eventually we'll
replace it with something else but it's
been good for
now I will say that uh like a lot lot of
Engineers will probably like it cuz they
like they want something that looks more
familiar but still
fast sion's pretty
thing I'm basically what I'm trying to
do is figure out how to make it so that
you can simulate multiple ocean
environments per core so that you don't
have to do the loop yourself in Python
if you don't want to um which it is
always going to be faster to handle your
own Loops but we should be able to make
it
decent and it's uh being
weird welcome YouTube
folks happy
Sunday why is bat size
one what I want want to know like we've
got num m is
four oh wait wait wa wait I think
there's isn't there like M bat size or
something yeah I'm
done this has got to be two
so it runs but it's not giving us any
stats
back I me see so it's going to
wrap and just so you can see if I leave
the default settings this uses a
different code
pathway and now we get
this it's got to be in serial
right I'm saying
so I think I have the same API
uh I think the format of the data is
different right
yeah there you go so literally just
minor data format
cool 1.4 million steps per second
training as
well GPU is only on
56% so technically if anybody really
wants to help us optimize our our
training pipeline we could hit 2 million
step per second
training with puffer lip
well look G well I don't know how
accurate this GPU utilization thing is
from Nvidia I don't know if this is just
like but yeah if this is remotely
accurate at 1.4 mil we should be able to
hit 2 mil
right I mean we're not bot neck by
CPU we shouldn't be Bob neck by
GPU we're
losing we got 16% misscellaneous and
then 13%
miscellaneous maybe I just have to clean
up our miscellaneous code
I think that includes Cuda device
transfer so that might be like
async like async data queuing or
something that we got to
do but I'm pretty happy with
that this will be a very nice feature um
I'm trying to think what the easiest way
to test all this is
though so this definitely still works on
snake right
I mean I could just YOLO merge this to
be
fair okay let's do let's try some
different
Ms hi I'm using python for scientific
computations often time my code
generates a bunch of data and then I
plot it
are there any Version Control Systems
for data too yes compare different
graphs yeah uh w
b you just use WB for
that if you're not doing RL stuff
specifically then puffer is not going to
be particularly useful for you but like
all of our experiments are on puffer so
like here we have all these experiments
look I can compare these are like
different experiments I was running on
mo3 uh here you can see our crazy
Baseline where we ran this for like
literally 2025 years model
2025 so tons and tons of
data I would suggest to use that
breakout thanks yeah that's like the
standard thing that people use it has a
few issues with it but I think it's
generally the best thing out there
uh I have to change num workers to 16
here so that this will let me run
it B size must
be 16 *
3 uh
28 so the reason I have to change this
and puffer is just not working is
because this machine uh is different
core count
okay now this is a legitimate error
um changing the D type to a subarray
type is only
supported
multiprocessing I do get it without
multiprocessing okay
environment okay so it tells you you
have a 11 10580 observation
space and then it gives you
back well where's this observation come
from self observation
so in rware I just had big arrays for
map designs at the top of myh file in my
new M I want to start with a bunch of
levels any thoughts uh static levels or
procedural
levels right
leave them as do I mean you can just
leave them as as AR raise in near do AG
literally like think about it what are
you going to gain it's basically the
same format as like Json and stuff
anyways and you don't have to write a
parser like if just like actually this
is kind of an important concept like
think about it what do you gain by
trying to write
something uh write something than this
versus just pasting in a h if you really
hate having it at the top of the file
you can just make a data. h or a maps. h
and just include that
right but there's literally nothing that
you gain by doing that if you're not
going to have like a map editor or like
if you're not explicitly doing something
that requires a different structure
leave it as a simple thing
no over
complicate let me figure out why these
data shapes don't match up um some of
this Dev you know the dev on the stream
is not always going to be the most
interesting thing I'm doing like
lowlevel weird infrastructure stuff for
puffer right now and uh this
is so this is like a 460 line file that
was the original core that made puffer
lib exist um it does some fiddly
operations that make basically make it
so that you can do RL on very
complicated environments without having
to deal with all sorts of fancy like
data types and shapes
yourself um but there's a little bit of
trickiness to it
basically it's like a big flatten it
flattens all your data and then UNF
flattens it right when you need it but
doing that correctly is kind of
fast observation space okay so why right
here I can see that the for some reason
the observation space doesn't match the
data coming from the environment and it
worked before so I must have broken
something
small
um what could I have broken
though except
buffers
oh yeah this is
it
um because I have this numb agents in
the buffer
here yeah it's because I have numb
agents in the buffer and it's a single
agent environment okay that's
fine that's an easy
fix I think
use GPT for obscure
docks cuz I don't know how this thing
works
I my expectation is that we should be
able to get
DET yeah we should it should be fine
um for
reinterpret the data as having a subad
type is total item
size no longer matches the original
buffer why does this change the
size idea is
that each
LM has some
shape total array
is is like bat size
shape
memory and layout copies
Alters per element item
size okay so there's just some weird
casting Shenanigans going on then
this does this
work no okay so it's still it's not
why does it work when I
do Works in other cases
right oh I think it works in other cases
though because
no this should work because
self-observations
is self
observation
type yeah this is just bytes I should be
able to view bytes however I want
right so like if I run the same thing
with
um like puffer
spaces and this is kind of a cool thing
in numpy you can
do okay so you see I have like this
really weird structure D type here
observations these are just
bites and then if I hit n
here
obstruct
oops uh I continued one too many
times look at that you get a view into
the into those raw bites
um but it's structure so now like you
can access this you can access this as
if it were a structured array and the
structure has this like a flat portion
and an image
portion so it's basically a structured
way to view contiguous
memory so why doesn't this work on the
other the other case
I see I have like d type
of flat image align is
true and
then
space emulated dtype
is G type from space
if it's a
tuple you
recurse
else okay so this is weird it should
have aligned this right
is
align false okay well that makes no
sense because I manually aligned it
right unless uh it doesn't get here
right dtype is space dtype space. shape
B
type b. dtype D type
it's funny that actually it only works
for complex SS as it is
maybe numai just doesn't have this so
that you don't do it because it's like a
flat
case
and I'm just doing something weird where
like the way I have this structured this
has to be special case whereas normally
it would be the default
cereal there's obviously a print
somewhere
22k
solid spins your CPU like nuts okay well
this is good progress um I'm going to
have to apply this to multi-agent Ms and
then I'm going to have to clean some
stuff up uh I'm going to take a few
minutes and then I will be back be back
in a
okay um I'm going pretty soon but I want
to make sure we get this brunches early
apparently here the holidays there's
some family around I may or may not do
an afternoon stream today we will
see but this is going pretty
nicely I really don't like how much
stuff has to get repeated across
gymnasium and pettings and that's just
why
they're the two apis are a total
pain
um this code probably has to
go I can just YOLO this onto the uh
yeah to right here
maybe I mean I know I've thought about
this code like so many times and like if
there's a way to simplify it there just
really isn't get rid of these at
least I kind of don't really bother too
much with him because eventually we're
just going to replace both of these apis
entirely like we're building so many new
environments in puffer lib um and like
we're directly collaborating with people
building other M's that eventually I
think we'll just have everything on
either on the puffer one or something
that's like a very close wrapper away
from puffer and then we just won't have
to
care which would be nice uh do I even
have like a
good
multi-agent test for this the thing they
really aren't
like they just aren't good environments
to test stuff with fish let's try this
big
fish
16 oh it is 96 though right this work
is yeah now I have to modify all the
environment this is the the price that I
have to pay for this
here there you
go it's actually a bit FAS F than before
7.5 the environment's super fast here
it's just their default models really
slow
now never mind I got 45 minutes
apparently yeah even
I push something for like 30 minutes and
already people uh get the wrong version
it's like damn
this I actually highly recommend this if
you're not trying to be insane and have
like a th000 calorie protein shake you
can make the exact same thing with just
whole milk instead of heavy cream and
it's a 500 calorie
shake so this is all paid off with the
morning
run so yeah I have to change all all the
bloody environments is the annoying
thing
sweet I'm really not as concerned
anymore with all these like third party
mends because very few people use most
of these and
um like very few people actually use
these and they're slow anyways like we
have all sorts of new environments for
people to use now so like I think we
it's always very risky to just like say
now we're going to do our own thing and
like move everything mostly onto that
but I think it's actually good enough to
now uh where that makes that actually
makes real
sense like do you even really need I
guess like oh it's a classic task or
whatever but like do you really care
care about like evaluating on Mountain
car when you just have better
environments I mean we could make our
own version of this if people really
wanted
it like it wouldn't be
hard maybe we should have our own cart
pull just to show people how stupidly
fast it can
I think that we changed I owe them work
on this so we'll do this one
later but at least I want to make sure
that we don't have
you know I think honestly the most
viable thing for
us
um is going to be to just like get
everyone using puffer with all the new
environments and then just like anything
that people
need uh is going to end up being on
puffer So eventually we're going to make
like the third party stuff
obsolete um but we're not going to just
like OB like stop supporting it it's
more that I think we'll just be able to
make all the environments that people
will want to use because they will be
fast maybe with the exception of um like
robotic stuff but then we'll just work
with those people to make sure stuff's
compatible
like these environments don't even work
because and it's no fault of puffer Li
that they don't they're just they're
made for like such old versions of
python and stuff they just haven't been
maintained in like seven years
I would like to test net hack though net
hack's
cool so we'll do
that oops right
m is actually decent here it's just yeah
we can definitely make this this a lot
faster if people want
okay so you
actually this is uh Kim's
work go follow on X if you are
interested
in continuous
Joo NE hack we actually do care about as
well
I really like net hack if anybody wants
to uh really try to make net hack work I
would be very
supportive and puffer Li do offline RL
if someone has a lot of training data
sitting
around uh no we don't have offline stuff
at the moment but the thing is
like if online learning is this hard
offline learning is like you got to dig
for it it's just super vised learning I
mean you can literally just write you
can write up like offline learning and I
don't know 150 lines of code and there's
like there's nothing clever to do there
either it's literally just supervised
learning you don't have any of the
issues of um of like getting data from
simulators or
trivial I don't work on offline just
simply because there's like there's
really nothing to do there
I mean it's like one of those things
where like look if if some company
really wanted just like to use our RL
expertise and like let's say they wanted
like carb stuff like our carbs
Integrations for offline or like they
wanted you know us to look at stuff in
that way then yeah we could do it it's
just it's a pretty big deviation from
what I'm trying to do with puffer know
so there'd be a premium on it um but
alternatively it's like it's not that
hard so if you want offline support in
puffer for free just like PR it and then
we'll test it against all our
environments right can be it's a pretty
easy way to do
stuff like it's we're not going to
reject PRS that just like you know a
simple offline script compatible with
on that's kind of how we do
stuff and the way I see it is
like I have an agenda in my head for how
I see RL being fixed in the next 12
months and anything that is going to
anything that's going to like
deviate a little from that is like
premium stuff and anything that's going
to deviate a lot from that is extra
premium stuff
n hack works it's even faster than
before that's probably just this machine
being
better I did actually make a couple
fixes that could have improved that come
to think of it
I would like to make sure neural MMO at
least
bug that's nice we actually get a bug
fix out of this
D that is so
sad look at
this Nur Mo 3 literally
trains with the same size model
over a 100 times faster
class we do care about Pokémon Pokemon
is a active supported project under
puffer it's very cool project in
fact there's their own uh we have our
own Discord for that as
well most of the work there's being done
by that guy though there've been several
other contributors
prior does this
work for
SP David
hen I chatted with him at ner so when
his honor I will make sure his
environment Works provided it is not
cursed
oh yeah it's like an old version of of
python I think right yeah it's annoying
well this will I The Binding is going to
be just as good as it was before
annoying we also don't really do
smack it's like just slow and nobody
uses
it no
point and like stable retro it's like
really cool project in theory but you
can only run one of these per process
and it's slow it's
like I guess we it like we could try
really hard if we wanted to but like
there's no point
class think we'll leave that for
now do you have a 3D Puff for us we do
indeed do you uh do you have an
environment in
mind are you going to make it the ball
in uh the code game the code ball
game in fact the 3D the animation that
we have where it puffs up and stuff we
have that in 3D as
well might make it the hero of the story
story that sounds
fun
boing yeah so we do have 3D models I I
got to figure out how to separate like
the animations out but yeah I can get
you those
what are you
doing currently fixing up some
environments for the new infrastructure
and Puffer that makes parallel
simulation a little easier we'll come
back to puffer very
hardware oh yeah I remember that I'm
sure it works it's
fine Doom specifically is a little
quirky okay but this should be a decent
um decent pack
I guess I'll go get like the squared
python
code for a test environment I've got
like 20 minutes before I got to go I
might be able to finish that
code do you think setting up little 3D
running animations is hard in Raab I
haven't tried I mean the uh code ball
stuff uh in the Discord somebody's been
doing
it and you can try it and let me
know if it's hard or not
it' be nice to know because
like there are a lot of games we could
make 3D front ends for you
know like uh impulse Wars could very
easily have a 3D front end 2D Sim 3D
front end it's a pretty fun
one basically I'm just porting the uh
this environment to Pure python as a
little demo for people
is True Rewards
is
1.0 then you
do s. reset
Okay isn't it crazy how this code is
literally the same length in Python I
guess you don't have the memory
allocations and stuff
but it's like not any easier
um self.
rewards ah I see how I did
this
render oops looks like I got to go in a
second hold
on got like 5 minutes going to brunch
with
family if I get this word
I think I have to add num Ms for
now kind of
silly Le we get real errors
um out of bounds for size one
one and 121 okay so this is
actually you got to do like a zero
all right I got a run I'll fix this
later it's almost there it's like almost
almost there
um
run no still no okay we'll fix this
later uh thanks for tuning in folks join
discord.
GPU if you want to follow the project
I'm on xjar 5341 as well I post a bunch
of far out and I'll be streaming this a
lot if you want to help out the project
for free Star Puffer lip